Pete Davidson was just photographed
hanging out with kaya Gerber and we are
not okay the Saturday Night Live star
and Cindy Crawford's daughter were
snapped by a fan spending time together
at Hsu Dells restaurant in New York City
yep that's the 25 year olds comedian and
the 18 year old model sitting in a
corner booth smiling away
who else is shook okay now it's not
clear if these two are thing or if
they're just friends but honestly I
cannot keep up with Pete's love life
these days let's see in August he and
Margaret quality sparked romance rumors
then they were spotted together a few
times in September he even attended the
premiere of her flick Seberg at the 2019
Venice Film Festival but their rumored
love was short-lived and fizzled out
fast they reportedly called it quits
last week before Margaret Pete was
linked to Kate Beckinsale and while they
were hot and heavy for a sec that
fizzled out too in April a source
confirmed to et that the pair was still
friends but not on romantic terms then
of course there's this before Kate P got
engaged to Ariana Grande after less than
a month of dating before calling it off
just a few months later which led to the
release of Ariana's single girl anthem
thank you next
as for kaya she's kept her dating life
pretty private but she was spotted
earlier this year with model Wellington
grant the two sparked romance rumours in
early February when he posted this
picked his insta story having a thumb
war with kaya backstage at the Stella
McCartney show yeah you heard me right a
thumb war like one two three four I
declare a thumb war Oh young love anyhoo
they were also seen cozying up on
Valentine's Day before they were snapped
holding hands during a New York stroll
but the last time they were photographed
together was in April when they grabbed
dinner with kaya's famous parents in an
interview with British Vogue in
September kya admitted that her crazy
work schedule didn't leave a lot of time
for love quote when I'm working I don't
have the energy to even flirt with
anyone I'm sorry I just can't but I'm
not losing hope in all of forever
they definitely leave time to do normal
teenage things and I feel like even
though I have had to miss out on some
things like that normal teenagers do
this makes it over here now we did a
little investigative journalism for you
you're welcome
and get this in June Pete made his
runway debut for Alexander Wang kaya
also walked in that show okay so not to
jump to conclusions and happily ever
afters but if these two are in fact a
couple and they get married she
definitely needs to wear Alexander Wang
am i right just saying of course
et will be right here to keep you
up-to-date on this possible budding
romance so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]